باتت مدمره بشكل كامل هذه صور نشرها
التلفزيون الروسي مؤكدا سيطره القوات
الروسيه على بلده مارينكا التي كانت تعتبر
قلعه محصنه للقوات الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع
الروسي خلال لقاء مع الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين اكد على اهميه هذا النصر الذي من
شانه ان يقلل من القدرات الدفاعيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط
دونتسك اولا وقبل كل شيء اود ان اهنئك على
هذا النجاح ثانيا والاهم من ذلك ارجو ان
تنقل احر تهاني وكلمات الامتنان لجميع
الافراد ولجميع الجنود الذين شاركوا على
مدار المراحل المختلفه في تحرير
مارينكا هذا التقدم الذي تحدث عنه الرئيس
الروسي نا فاه الجيش الاوكراني مشيرا الى
ان القتال للسيطره على مارينكا مستمر
ومؤكدا على ان جنودا اوكرانيين لازالوا
متواجدين في البلده مارينكا مهمه جدا
للجيش الاوكراني الذي اقام فيها تحصينات
منذ عام
2014 حين بدا النزاع مع الانفصاليين
الموالين لروسيا الذين سيطروا على مدينه
دونتسك